Endlich scheint es loszugehen nach einem tödlichen testflug ist virgin galactic. Wo kurz davor seine weltraumflüge für touristen in die tat umzusetzen
Das unternehmen hat mehrere erfolgreiche tests wirklich jetzt vor kurzem absolviert in wenigen monaten vielleicht sogar
Noch in diesem jahr will die firma von richard branson. Dann die ersten touristenflüge ins all anbieten
Sensationell wie realistisch ist das aber jetzt in klicks, um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Ehrlich gesagt hatte ich virgin galactic fast aus den augen verloren wenn jetzt nicht jemand auf whatsapp nach dem stand der dinge gefragt hätte
Dann, gäbe ist dieses video auch nicht knapp vier. Jahre ist der schwere crashs bei einem. Testflug her bei dem
Ein mensch starb und ein weiterer schwer verletzt wurde jetzt ist die wie ss unity des unternehmens virgin galactic wieder
Erfolgreich in die luft gestartet zusammen mit überschallgeschwindigkeit. Und zudem auch mit eigenem antrieb bei den vergangenen tests lügen war es entweder
Ohne eigenen antrieb zur erde zurück blicken oder war die gesamte zeit am trägerflugzeug
Befestigt gestartet wurde dieses mal in der kalifornischen mojave-wüste 14 kilometer über dem erdboden wurde das raketenflugzeug vom trägerflugzeug
Aus gelingt 30 sekunden dauert es wohl die motoren gezündet hatten bis auf macht
1,87 also
1,87 fache schallgeschwindigkeit
Habe es dann beschleunigt. Und so eine. Höhe von fast 26 kilometern erreicht danach sei die uss unity. Zur erde zurück geschwebt
Und gelandet dabei war wohl, auch der sogenannte feder modus am flugzeug
Eingesetzt worden bei dem die flügel in einem winkel von 65 grad zum rumpf gedreht werden die. Ihn so
Stabilisieren dieser extreme winkel der flügel darf nur im sinkflug aktiviert werden
Und weil der co-pilot diese im oktober 2014 zu früh ausgelöst hatte war es überhaupt erst zu dem schlimmen crash bekommt
Er hat die federn noch in der schublade freigegeben die flügel drehten sich in diesen extremen winkeln
Und zerrissen die wie ss. Enterprise die
Aktuelle wie ss unity ist übrigens unter der federführung eines
Anderen, unternehmens entstanden als damals die verunglückte wie ss
Enterprise jetzt soll es nicht mehr möglich sein den fehler modus während der
Zündung zu aktivieren insgesamt sollen fünf dieser raketen flugzeuge entsteht das raketenflugzeug des britischen unternehmens richard bransons
Ist vom typ
Spaceshiptwo sechs passagiere und zwei piloten finden in dem platz der firmenboss demonstriert damit dass, er an die
eigene technik noch
ungebrochen glaubt er selbst weder bei der premiere
des ersten
Weltraumtouristen fluges tatsächlich mit dabei sein. Und ja das an es soll den angaben des unternehmens schon in wenigen monaten
Stattfinden brands ist persönliches training dafür ist in vollem gang in einem interview mit der bbc sagte, er dass
Er sein tennis training jetzt von zwei auf vier spiele pro tag. Ausgewählt habe zudem mache, er, ein astronautentraining aber auch
Alle anderen interessierten können die sache jetzt schon dingfest machen der seine firma verkauft jetzt schon die tickets
250.000 dollar ja ein klacks müssen die passagiere daraufhin legen, um etwa sechs minuten
Schwerelosigkeit zu erleben in einer. Höhe von etwa
110 kilometern das gilt das untere grenze des weltraums dennoch lässt sich sogar die krümmung der erdkugel aus dieser
Höhe erkennen. Und man kann viele grüße an die flat erst schicken nach unternehmensangaben sollen schon rund 600 tickets verkauft
Worden seien vom spaceport. America im us bundesstaat new. Mexico. Sollen
Dann, die starts erfolgen wir haben hierbei klicks und science fiction ja schon öfter darüber berichtet. Und übermorgen die firma von amazon gründer
jeff bezos die liefert sicher mit virgin galactic schon seit längerem
ein spannendes
Kopf-an-kopf- rennen darum wer als erstes touristen in den weltraum schicken kann anders als virgin galactic tüfteln die macher von blue origin
Aber an einer art raumkapsel die mithilfe vom fallschirm zurück auf die erde schweben soll auch
Sie, sollen noch in diesem jahr. Zum ersten mal ins weltall fliegen. Und zwar bemannt unbekannt ist sie schon
Mehrmals geflogen schätzungen zufolge dürfte der preis für solche ticket nicht die schwelle von
50.000 dollar überschreiten so dramatisch viel billiger ein klacks quasi ja damit sich die weltraumflüge tatsächlich zum massentourismus
entwickeln können na ja für 50.000 dollar doch noch haben die sicherheitsbehörden dem
Noch nicht zugestimmt eventuell wird der durchbruch dazu auch gar nicht in den usa passieren sondern in saudi arabien
Das bereit ist enorm zu investieren dem land geht es dabei nicht nur, um touristenflüge ins all sondern auch
um
Fliegende plattformen für satellitenstarts es tut also sich so einiges in dem es tut sich also
einiges in dem bereich hier bei pixar vater natürlich immer
Alles über die
Jüngsten entwicklung auch weil die community auf sap also im weg hält hier mal einen riesen riesen dank an euch
Ihr seid hammer wenn. Ihr die noch nicht dabei sie mitmachen wollt dann endet. Mich bei websense da könnte, er in der redaktion mitmachen
Und dann verpasst ja auch kein video über whatsapp erfahrt. Ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich und garantiert
Und zur begrüßung habe ich ein kleines geschenk für euch einfach hier draufklicken
Und am besten auch mein schwesterkanal klicks. Um
Social and media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
Genau, die glocke vergessen. Und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken falcon heavy die revolution der raumfahrt. Bis. Dann
bleibt dran